that's my honey vanessa hudgens getting  some support from a longtime boyfriend  Austin Butler at the New York premiere  of her new movie second act I mean I  think it's so important to have a person  who is your rock but don't call it a  date night I mean my date nights usually  don't consist of as many cameras and  more clothes not freezing normally yes  he's a wonderful supportive though so  happy to have him here Vanessa  stunned in a rose inspired dress by Marc  Jacobs favorite part of the outfit I  mean it's incredible I feel like a  walking piece of art I'm cold and you  would never tell but it is very tight  very tight also tight Vanessa's bond  with co-star JLo I really admire you  kind of who I want to be when I grow up  I feel so lucky to work with Jen because  she was just one of those people that I  got working with and felt like I had  known her my whole life which does not  always happen